Ya hemos contestado varias preguntas acerca
de los distintos planes que hay en el estudio
de Súper Yoga y lo hicimos usando las ecuaciones
que habíamos obtenido, pero yo soy un tipo
visual y me gustaría ver, analizar bien la
información antes de gastarme los dólares
que tanto trabajo me han costado ganar.
Así es que lo que voy a hacer ahora es una representación visual acerca de cuantas sesiones
voy a tener y cuantos dólares me va a costar
y lo voy a hacer para el plan de prueba
y para el plan básico.
Y para hacer eso, aquí abajo, en este eje horizontal voy a graficar el número de sesiones
"s", el número de sesiones por mes que voy
a tener y en el eje vertical voy a graficar
cuanto me va a costar dependiendo el número
de sesiones que voy a tomar,
voy a graficar "c", lo cual es mi costo mensual.
Entonces consideremos estos puntos de aquí
y también consideremos esta ecuación,
cómo se va a ver esta ecuación cuando la grafiquemos.
Este primer punto de aquí establece que si yo atiendo a 0 sesiones y no voy a ninguna sesión,
eso me va a costar 0 dólares,
no voy a pagar nada.
¿Cómo ubico ese punto en la gráfica?
Y viéndolo bien, necesito marcar el valor
de 0 para "s" que me va a costar 0 dólares,
y este es el punto 0, 0.
Ahora, si asisto a una sesión, me va a costar 12 dólares,
¿cómo ubico ese punto en mi gráfica?
Si asisto a una sesión me va a costar 12
dólares, aquí tenemos el 15, un poquito
más abajo es el 12, aquí tenemos el punto 1, 12.
Ahora, 2 sesiones me van a costar 24 dólares,
vamos a ubicar ese punto, 2 sesiones,
me van a costar 24, aquí un poquito abajo de 25,
este es el punto 2, 24.
Ahora, cuando tomo 3 sesiones, y podría seguir
así, 4, 5, 6 sesiones, pero creo que con
esto ya nos damos una idea de que es lo que sucede, cuando tomo 3 sesiones me cuesta 36 dólares,
ubiquemos el punto 3 sesiones, 36 dólares.
Ya puedes ver que estos puntos se ubican sobre
una recta, déjame trazar la recta
y esta línea describe todas las posibles combinaciones de costo dado el número de sesiones que se toman,
cualquier punto, sobretodo si estamos suponiendo que se permiten sesiones fraccionadas,
esta no es una práctica común,
usual en los estudios de yoga, pero estamos hablando
del estudio Súper Yoga donde puedes tomar
4 sesiones y media, 2 sesiones y media
o si tomas media sesión, te cuesta 6 dólares.
Otra manera de ver esto, es bueno, si no tomas
sesiones te cuesta 0 dólares,
pero si tomas una sesión... si tomas una sesión, el costo se va a incrementar en 12 dólares,
al incrementar una sesión, el costo se va a incrementar en 12 dólares,
así es que al incrementar una sesión, el costo se incrementó en 12 dólares, si incrementamos
otra sesión, nuevamente hay un incremento
de costo de 12 dólares, así fuimos de 0
a 12, luego a 24, si agregamos otra sesión
incrementamos otros 12, llegamos a 36,
si quitamos una sesión disminuimos el costo
en 12, de lo que se trata es de ver que tan
inclinada es esta recta, si avanzas uno a
la derecha, hay que subir 12.
Ahora, hagamos lo mismo para el plan básico,
¿cómo vamos a graficar esto?
Empecemos...
empecemos con este punto,
cuando las sesiones son 0, cuando no he ido a ninguna sesión, hay un costo de 20 dólares.
¿Cómo graficamos eso?
Vayamos a nuestra gráfica, cuando número
de sesiones es 0 el costo es de 20.
¿Qué pasa si hay una sesión?
Si hay una sesión, el costo es 28...
si hay una sesión, el costo es 28
ó podemos pensar que si se aumenta una sesión,
si agregas una sesión el costo total aumenta en 8...
si agregas una sesión el costo total aumenta en 8.
Este eje y este eje no tienen la misma escala,
si tuvieran la misma escala, la recta se iría
mucho más inclinada y este eje sería muchísimo
más grande, pero espero que captes la idea,
aumentas una sesión, el costo aumenta en 8.
Así es que por una sesión pagamos 28,
es este punto que tenemos aquí,
por 2 sesiones pagamos 36 dólares,
por 2 sesiones pagamos 36,
¿dónde lo voy a graficar eso?
2 sesiones, 36 dólares, más o menos por aquí...
más o menos por aquí o insistimos que una
manera de ver esto es aumentas una sesión
y el costo se incrementa en 8 dólares,
así es que 28 dólares más 8 dólares,
nos da 36 dólares.
Continuemos graficando este punto.
¿Cómo ubicamos en la gráfica 3 sesiones?
Si vamos a 3 sesiones nos va a costar 44 dólares,
esto se va a ubicar más o menos por aquí,
más o menos por ahí.
Y de nueva cuenta, hemos agregado una sesión
e incrementamos el costo en 8 dólares.
Y aquí puedes ver que estos puntos, estos puntos también parecen estar sobre una línea recta...
también parecen estar sobre una línea recta...
déjame graficarla, voy a tratar de hacerlo
lo mejor posible.
Aquí tenemos...
esta sería la recta que conecta los puntos,
esto en sí mismo es interesante,
pero lo que es más interesante es,
¿dónde se intersectan estas 2 rectas?
Vemos que tienen diferentes inclinaciones,
así es que en algún punto deben de intersectarse
y lo que es interesante de eso...
voy a dejar que tú pienses que es lo interesante
del punto intersección y que tiene que ver
eso con el costo y las sesiones.
¿Qué tiene que ver le punto de intersección con esto?
Vamos a dejarlo ahí y exploraremos esto en
el siguiente video.